I can't believe we're doing this one  what happens to raid Shadow Legends in  the Clockworks intern Sora prepared one  iPhone 6 with the YouTube app installed  and placed it into scp-914 on the  setting fine the output produced was one  raid Shadow Legends iPhone 6 with the  app raid Shadow Legends installed has a  raid Shadow Legends Cognito hazardous  effect when upon viewing will cause the  raid Shadow Legends viewer 2 raid Shadow  Legends become unable to describe  objects with raid Shadow Legends  anything except the phrase raid Shadow  Legends effect removed after application  of amnestics God I won't be able to live  that down